you think you're watching Tick Tock but
in reality it's watching you yeah those
cute fun little videos come at a high
price your privacy
but now this app is banned permanently
and you might be better off without it
how is Tick Tock spying on you
how could watching too many tick tocks
make you ill
and why would Banning the app not solve
anything
this is what if and here's what would
happen if Tick Tock was banned
Tick Tock has taken over phone's
worldwide it's been growing way too big
way too fast in just four years over 3
billion people have downloaded the app
what started as a lip syncing video
sharing service has become one of the
world's largest media companies
everyone in your family is probably
scrolling through its videos right now
why are your eyes so glued to the screen
well because the site's algorithm is
constantly learning
it's dedicated to giving you what you
want when you want it which is always
right now
you've been feeding this Beast your
private data for years so what does this
monster become
having all your personal information in
the digital realm is a frightening
concept but for data Brokers it's big
business data Brokers are online
companies that collect your personal
information and sell it to anyone who
can pay sometimes these companies work
with the bad guys Epsilon one of the
largest data Brokers around was forced
to pay millions of dollars back to
victims after they knowingly sold user
data to scammers the scammers promise
people fake prizes auto warranties even
non-existent medical cures that's why
I'm glad to talk to you today about our
sponsor incogni this company Works
around the clock to request the removal
of your information from these databases
it could take years to do this on your
own manually but through their Advanced
automated system incognate keeps your
data off the market by conducting
repeated ongoing removals they handle
all the objections that the Brokers
might have and keep you updated through
email L every step of the way all you
have to do is sign up subscribe and let
them handle the rest the best part is
that their service is risk-free for 30
days so if you're not satisfied you get
a full refund and the first 100 people
to use the code what if at the link
below will get 20 off their subscription
look it's easy to get scared of the
invisible threats online but within
cogney it's much easier to take action
now let's get back to the video
listen Tick Tock knows you better than
you know yourself but what do you know
about it
well for one its headquarters are
located in Beijing China that means over
3 billion users private data belongs to
a company subject to the whims of a
strict and often totalitarian government
and according to China's laws if the
government demands to see data
Tick Tock had better hand it over fast
yeah your digital life would be in the
hands of president for Life Xi Jinping
now there's no evidence that Tick Tock
is spying on you so you can take that
tape off your camera but the app does
collect information about your phone
your usage patterns and locations
it even uses third-party tracking
services
yeah a certain foreign government always
knows where you are
now as far as we know China hasn't
crossed any of these lines but India
wasn't taking any chances
India banned Tick-Tock and other Chinese
apps claiming that China's government
stole their citizens data even former
U.S president Trump flirted with Banning
the social media juggernaut
I mean he chickened out but what if the
United States banned Tick-Tock today
well your favorite content creators
would have to find new gigs fast
some creators make hundreds of thousands
of dollars per post
pull the plug and in just minutes many
of these overnight Sensations would lose
their Fame and fortunes forever
but what about you and your not so
famous friends
about one-third of the people on the
platform use tick tock as a news source
cutting people off from this information
pipeline could be damaging and these
aren't just random videos strung
together Tick Tock has online
communities based on sharing knowledge
life hacks and medical advice
these groups and their creators would
have to go to another social media
platform or they could disappear from
the internet
and that's not the only way our culture
could change
remember that algorithm is designed to
give you that dopamine rush for hours on
end
unless or until a new app fills the Gap
people might spend less time on their
phones
what as you might have guessed that
could actually improve Society in 2021
neurologists noted an uptick in the
number of teenage girls experiencing
symptoms of Tourette Syndrome such as
making sounds or movement they couldn't
easily control
but they didn't have the disease so what
caused their new behaviors
they had a sociogenic illness
this phenomenon occurs when people in
certain social groups exhibit bizarre
symptoms without any medical explanation
the girls were watching so many videos
on Tourette's syndrome and other
disorders that they believed they had
the syndrome tick tock's algorithm gave
the young women so much specialized
content that it affected their minds and
bodies so without Tick Tock supplying
this information non-stop some people's
mental health might improve
now the U.S federal government can't
make a Tick-Tock ban a nationwide
reality but if you use a device owned by
the United States government a new law
says you can't use it to access Tick
Tock and some states have banned the
social media app from their government
devices
now these bands are pretty meaningless
India banned Tick-Tock but anyone with a
virtual private Network or VPN can still
use the app
but think of it if people spent less
time on their phones well they might
spend more time with their loved ones
and that intimacy could lead to a
population boom
now what if we had a 50-year ban on
babies
well keep the lights on Romeo and stay
right here because that's a story
for another
what if
[Music]